what's the worst part of any vacation
sharks no going back to work on Monday
that's where I come into you from
American Express studios with a few
smart ways to detox after your next big
trip we all come back tired and hungry
so set up a grocery delivery for the day
you return have a stocked fridge when
ordering go for super foods like salmon
almond and avocados
they're high in omega-3s which will help
raise your system of toxins keep
antioxidants and probiotics on hand to
get your systems back on track this
smoothie is packed with both just add
kale blueberries ginger flaxseed and
Greek yogurt flush toxins and lose
excess sodium by powering up your
hydration routine adding lemon to your
water and replacing coffee with
dandelion tea for a few days will help
do this one last thing use coconut oil
to bring back the moisture that you lost
during your flight it's great for your
face and body and will help bring back
that healthy glow how do you bounce back
after a big trip tell us in the comments
[Music]